Queridos amigos, durante los últimos tiempos
hemos publicado un montón de videos sobre
Venezuela y la terrible situación política
que este país atraviesa.
Os hemos contado cómo se ha llegado hasta
aquí;
cuáles son las características básicas
de esta narcodictadura
y qué ha supuesto una revolución, la revolución
bolivariana, que ha condenado a la pobreza
a la mayor parte de los venezolanos y que,
incluso, está provocando uno de los mayores
éxodos de toda la historia.
(Los refugiados venezolanos ahora suman 3.4
millones; implicaciones humanitarias masivas,
advierte la ONU.)
Sin embargo mientras los acontecimientos se
precipitan a una velocidad de vértigo con
este hombre, Juan Guaido, liderando una firme
oposición al régimen de Maduro, hemos pensado
que nos faltaba hacer un repaso general a
una cuestión fundamental:
¿Quiénes son los principales aliados de
Nicolás Maduro? ¿Quiénes y por qué, a
pesar de todo, siguen apoyando este régimen?
¿Qué intereses tienen?
Amigos puede parecer increíble dadas las
circunstancias, pero el régimen chavista
sigue teniendo importantes aliados.
Atentos porque estos son los 4 socios más
grandes, los 4 mayores aliados que sigue teniendo
el sátrapa venezolano.
(4º - HOY POR TI, MAÑANA POR MI)
En 2010 comenzó una bonita amistad. [Mejor
dicho, una terrible amistad]
Ese año Nicolás Maduro viajó a Turquía
como Canciller de Venezuela. Allí conoció
al presidente turco Tayyip Erdogan.
(“Son dos políticos que se sienten atacados
por Occidente y la base de la relación es
sobre todo emocional [...] Erdogan no olvida
que Maduro fue uno de los primeros líderes
que le apoyó durante el intento de golpe
de Estado del 15 de julio de 2016. Ahora Turquía
está devolviendo el apoyo recibido” Mehmet
Ozkan, Center for Global Policy de Washington.)
Vamos, para que nos entendamos, que es una
relación basada en algo así como:
[“oye, mira, que resulta que el resto del
mundo nos ha puesto en la diana, ya ves sólo
porque dicen que somos autoritarios, como
si fuera algo malo poner orden ya ves tú,
que no respetamos la libertad de prensa dicen.
En fin, que si te parece pues tu me apoyas
y yo te apoyo]
(Estos líderes populistas y autoritarios
están tratando de desarrollar relaciones
de hombre a hombre, en lugar de confiar en
instituciones, burocracias o reglas ".)
El caso, amigos, es que desde que se produjera
el golpe de estado turco - o según se sospecha
el autogolpe de estado - el comercio entre
ambos países se ha multiplicado por 13.
Tan solo en 2018, las exportaciones de Venezuela
a Turquía superaron los 1.000 millones de
dólares.
Y no, no penséis que se trata de productos
industriales o incluso agrícolas, para nada.
Fundamentalmente se trata de la última fuente
de divisas con las que el régimen venezolano
trata de ganar oxígeno. Estoy hablando del
oro.
Y es que, veréis, Turquía se ha convertido
en algo así como el centro de refinado, certificación
y distribución del oro venezolano. Por así
decirlo, el centro de lavado perfecto para
que el gobierno de Nicolás Maduro pueda seguir
obteniendo divisas.
[Algo cada vez más complicado, especialmente
tras el colapso que está sufriendo la “industria”
petrolera]
(Las exportaciones de petróleo de Venezuela
cayeron a un mínimo de 28 años. Bloomberg)
Según parece el acuerdo firmado entre Venezuela
y Turquía, le estaría permitiendo a Caracas
evadir las sanciones de los Estados Unidos.
(Misteriosa firma turca ayudó a Maduro a
mover $ 900 millones en oro. Bloomberg)
Durante los últimos meses ha sido frecuente
ver en el aeropuerto de Caracas Jet privados
procedentes de Rusia y Turquía; alguno de
ellos, por cierto, propiedad de Ciner [yinér],
una empresa minera muy cercana al presidente
Erdogan.
Pues bien, lo que se sospecha es que estos
aviones están llegando a Caracas para sacar
oro del país de una forma bastante opaca.
[Vamos, que ya sabéis donde va a ir a parar
buena parte de todo este oro]
(Pero las relaciones aun van más allá. En
Diciembre de 2018, como quien dice antes de
ayer, Erdogan protagonizó la primera visita
de un jefe de estado turco a Venezuela.
Durante ese viaje se firmaron acuerdos comerciales
por más de 5.000 millones de dólares y se
anunció la creación de empresas conjuntas
para la exploración y explotación de carbón,
oro y petróleo.)
Por ejemplo, es muy significativo que las
industria alimentaria turca sea la proveedora
de cerca del 70% de los alimentos repartidos
por el gobierno de Venezuela bajo el programa
CLAP.
Pero, sigamos.
(3º ¿QUÉ HAY DE LO MIO?)
Es algo bien conocido, a lo largo de toda
la revolución bolivariana el papel de Cuba
ha sido trascendental.
Cuba le ha suministrado primero a Hugo Chávez
y luego a Nicolás Maduro, paramilitares,
protección, equipos de inteligencia… prácticamente
todo lo que los jerifaltes venezolanos han
necesitado para consolidar su poder.
(Venezuela es nueve veces más grande que
Cuba, tiene el triple de población y su economía
es cuatro veces mayor. El país alberga las
principales reservas de petróleo del mundo.
Sin embargo, algunas funciones cruciales del
Estado venezolano o han sido delegadas a funcionarios
cubanos o son directamente controladas por
La Habana. Moisés Naim)
[Puede ser polémico decirlo, pero seamos
claros, Cuba se ha convertido en algo así
como un supermercado del terror para los dictadores
de aquí y de allá]
Según el Secretario General de la Organización
de Estados Americanos, Luis Almagro, el número
de cubanos presentes en Venezuela se situaría
entre las 21.000 y las 46.000 personas.
(Rubio: agentes de Cuba dirigen represión
en Ureña, Venezuela. El Nuevo Herald)
(«Cuba es responsable de represión y tortura
en Venezuela» Luis Almagro, Secretario general
de la OEA)
Por supuesto, todo esto no ha sido gratis.
(A cambio de suministrar médicos y paramilitares,
Cuba ha recibido durante los últimos años
un montón de petróleo en condiciones más
que ventajosas del gobierno venezolano.
De hecho, aunque no tan importantes como los
fueron sus relaciones con la Unión Soviética,
durante la revolución bolivariana la economía
cubana ha sido muy dependiente de Venezuela.)
Sin embargo, amigos, tal y como están marchando
las cosas, aunque hoy por hoy todavía parecen
estar jugando un papel clave en la represión,
la isla no tiene ni de lejos los recursos
económicos para mantener en pie al narco-régimen
chavista.
[Vamos, que es posible que en el futuro su
mayor papel sea el de dar refugio a Nicolás
Maduro y sus compinches, si es que la DEA
no los captura antes]
(2º LOS NEGOCIOS SON LOS NEGOCIOS)
Si seguís habitualmente VisualPolitik lo
sabéis, le hemos prestado mucha atención
a las relaciones entre Caracas y Pekín.
Y no, no penséis que es una cuestión ideológica…
fue, es y probablemente será, con Maduro
y sin Maduro, una cuestión de negocios.
("El petróleo es la razón más fundamental
por la que China y Venezuela se unieron. China
necesitaba mucho petróleo y Venezuela lo
tenía [...] La relación floreció desde
entonces y ambos construyeron unos lazos basados
en "acuerdos de financiación por petróleo")
Veréis, los primeros acuerdos de préstamos
por petróleo entre China y Venezuela datan
del año 2007.
Para la Venezuela de Hugo Chávez estos acuerdos
significaron dinero fresco, contante y sonante
para su revolución. Para China, en cambio,
conseguir acceder a los enormes recursos energéticos
del país latinoamericano era algo que la
economía china necesitaba a toda costa.
Sus tasas de consumo de petróleo crecían
un motón año tras año y necesitaban lograr
la seguridad del suministro.
Y ojo porque no estamos hablando de poco dinero:
(Según los datos del Centro de Estudios Interamericano
y la Universidad de Boston, entre el año
2007 y el año 2018, China le prestó al país
latinoamericano casi 70.000 millones de dólares.
A día de hoy la deuda parece superar los
20.000 millones y para ser justos hay que
decir que Maduro no ha sido precisamente un
buen pagador.)
En Pekín confiaban que con todo el dinero
que habían puesto sobre la mesa, las autoridades
venezolanas conseguirían hacer algo productivo,
al menos invertir lo suficiente como para
mantener el nivel de producción de petróleo.
En Pekín jamás imaginaron que el gobierno
de Venezuela pudiera ser tan desastroso.
[Y como para los chinos todo esto es fundamentalmente
una cuestión de negocios, pues hemos visto
cosas como está:]
(China demanda a la compañía petrolera de
Venezuela por facturas impagadas. CNN)
A pesar de todo, en Pekín sospechan que si
se produce un cambio de gobierno sus acuerdos
podrían correr peligro, lo que podría suponer
no cobrar parte de la deuda que Venezuela
tiene que pagar en petróleo o, incluso, perder
el acceso privilegiado que están consiguiendo
a las enormes reservas venezolanas.
Precisamente por este motivo uno de los objetivos
que parece está persiguiendo el Presidente
Juan Guaido es convencer a los chinos de que
pase lo que pase los acuerdos se van a respetar.
(China habla con la oposición de Venezuela
para proteger sus inversiones. El Wall Street Journal.)
(No importa cómo evolucione la situación,
la cooperación entre China y Venezuela no
debe ser socavada ". Geng Shuang, Portavoz
del Ministerio de Relaciones Exteriores,)
En cualquier caso, amigos, si queréis saber
más sobre esta relación no os perdáis este
vídeo.
Y por último, la que tal vez sea la última
esperanza de Nicolás Maduro.
(1º UNA PUNTA DE LANZA CONTRA OCCIDENTE)
A día de hoy la Rusia de Putin es el mayor
respaldo internacional con el que cuenta el
régimen de Nicolás Maduro.
Durante las últimas dos décadas las empresas
rusas han logrado importantes contratos militares
y desde 2015, además, muchos derechos sobre
algunos de los campos de petróleo y gas más
importantes de Venezuela.
Todo lo han conseguido a precio de saldo.
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Fijaos.
(A cambio de un desesperado rescate de 1.500
millones de dólares, el gobierno venezolano
ha llegado a establecer como garantía, el
49,9% de su participación en Citgo, la joya
de la corona de PDVSA, una petrolera con actividad
en Estados Unidos donde es dueña de 3 refinerías,
una enorme red de gasoductos y casi 6.000
estaciones de servicio.
Si PDVSA no paga los 1.500 millones de dólares
de deudas contraídas con Rosneft y Gazprom,
Venezuela podría verse obligada a liquidar
a precio de saldo el que a día de hoy es
su activo industrial más valioso. Todo por
apenas 1.500 millones de dólares.)
Un momento, 1.500 millones por la mitad de
Citgo que vale muchísimo más, ¿estamos
de guasa? Bienvenidos a las rebajas de Maduro.
[Claro que tras las últimas sanciones de
Estados Unidos, todo esto puede haber quedado
en nada, entre otras cosas porque no parece
que este tipo de acuerdos vayan a ser reconocidos
por un gobierno, el de Estados Unidos, que
no reconoce como presidente a Nicolás Maduro]
El caso, amigos, es que Rusia se ha convertido
en el proveedor número uno de armas, equipos
militares e instrumentos de represión para
el gobierno venezolano:
misiles, tanques, aviones… el gobierno bolivariano
se ha gastado un dineral durante los últimos
años en equipos rusos.
Para Vladimir Putin Venezuela ha significado
un enorme negocio para la industria militar,
que tan importante es en Rusia, pero ahora
también lo ve como una oportunidad para seguir
metiendo el dedo en el ojo a Occidente al
tiempo que incrementa su control sobre algunas
de las mayores reservas energéticas del planeta.
En fin amigos, estos son los 4 aliados más
importantes con los que aún cuenta la narcodictadura
de Nicolás Maduro.
Junto a ellos estarían también países como
Bolivia, Nicaragua o Bielorrusia, pero con
una influencia en el mundo muy pequeña.
A la hora de la verdad, el gobierno bolivariano
va a hacer lo posible para ganarse un apoyo
total, expreso y firme de Rusia, China y Turquía
[El de Cuba ya lo tiene], aunque para ello
tenga que vender lo que queda de la mismísima
Venezuela.
Sin embargo… la debilidad política y el
caos creado por el gobierno chavista son tan
grandes que esto puede que ya no sea suficiente.
En fin, con este vídeo hemos querido situaros
mejor sobre quiénes siguen siendo los principales
valedores de todo este inmenso desastre.
Pero ahora turno para ti, y ojo que hoy os
dejamos una pregunta muy pero que muy importante:
¿Crees que Maduro conseguirá mantenerse
en el poder, al menos lo que queda de 2019?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.